e quando mai potrei iniziare un video di
pubblicità giapponesi senza giusto
outfit tra l'altro questa maglia quale
ho presa a disney si che è uno dei due
parchi disney che ci sono a tokyo sono
uno di fianco all'altro tra l'altro very
very very few times lescot ragazzi video
vi today già vice coraggio è per me il
video può concludersi può allora stiamo
parlando di una gelatina che va in bici
o se cose non le vedo neanche in è più
il spero nuova dehli nikon capisca ma
non ho capito cosa le ha detto ma
l'avrei detto mamma che carta e al posto
della testa possono stico chiappe ma chi
sono ma scaricavo prima sicuro non la
scarico adesso noi siamo stati momenti
aveva successo capo ritmi
in tacchi cosa c'è e cosa c'entra il kf
civico padri hanno fatto fettuccine gumi
non c'è niente che fa ridere questa
pubblicità stranamente maghi il titolo
del prodotto commercializzato sono le
fettuccine gumi quindi figure perché
sono a forma di effetti quanto è passato
all'inizio del video un minuto madonna
lunga oggi temo che gli sono fisso oddio
macero famiglia la seta grazioso
comunale socialista non ho capito un
cazzo
questa dicendo ma c'e robbie williams va
benissimo se dico che c'era anche io me
le cuffie fermi no guarda posso fare il
cosplay della ragazza in questo preciso
momento e vi farebbe benissimo
fantastico era capito i ragazzi non ho
capito niente di come mai
basta fate una roba seria vi prego mosti
c'e uno con l'hamburger buonissimo c'è
uno che urla l'hamburger quindi
probabilmente la moglie brucia i neuroni
o lo sa perché basta una rai e gli
hamburger
berna questo doppio di renderlo vabbè
ora detto niente non ho capito niente
fantasmi chissà se fanno età quanto
premia la caparbietà brehme 80 è quella
[Musica]
non è una fano è tutto tranne che fanno
ma neanche la finale non abbandona
particolare loro figlio lo sa bene chi
da silva basta george non reference
basta basta nei sensi si originò
economica quando non riuscì a dire il
perchè visto che l'altra volta la
capitale l'altro sono su uno yacht della
madonna e stanno giocando a puzzle and
dragons cioè loro sono qui c'è uno yacht
di cricket ed altro tenta un altro non
sarà che se esiste sto posto non penso
che sia computerizzato che non mai vista
roba del genere cioè vorrei vivere io
vado adesso adesso vado vado adesso è
comunque fidati che se esiste il suo
posto non giochi a paso ventre younes
non ci giochi ancora parlato la partita
bravo celeste conto che anche nella
nelle lavanderie a gettoni ci sono le
lavatrici che hanno venti volte
lavatrici nostre ciao ragazzi se
lavatrici qua reggono call of duty world
phone
cioè se tu lo installi c'è una tastiera
lo regge a era gli occhiali alla fine
bibite quest'anno la coca cola si per
forza azzeccato la la marca e figli
all'estero
[Musica]
ecco la liga dalla porta della rea la
cronaca la zia ma cosa ah no va bene
nuovo capito perché la coca cola in
giappone non ha la lattina solo a tutto
il distributore cioè tutte le lattine
fanno parte di un distributore di
proprietari la coca cola fichissima
sasha non lo sapevo c'è quindi quando
tocco acquisti che poi tanto non può
essere anche non coca cola ma una parte
va la coca cola perché dal distributore
è proprio suo
bellissima idea non si sa se ne va
quante scappare io ho sempre detto che
il nuovo
noi viviamo che non avrà mai un cazzo e
si manifesta e ciò che manca è capace
antenna per paipo che hanno sparo verità
non ho capito niente solo capito più di
port au prince
credo sia la honda è un miracolo noi
mettono la barca prima vi è qualche
nominarlo
vabbè i primi motorino ok
che cos'è sta roba la voglio è un
creatore di spezie nostre zie generators
materassi sidiqi ospite oa chi giappone
snack e tombe o 8 skinner crollato il
muro la casbah basta girare ragazzi vi è
crollata la casa siete morti non basta
girare tombe non ho capito niente però
perché la tipa era perché ci aveva una
coda cosa è successo io non capisco
niente della vita non capisco però stai
calmo stai calmo che già sei vecchio
film partenopei scritto sette tavole me
la sono immaginata la mia testa lei non
ha capito quello che lei ha detto perché
parla giapponese non capisce ancora egli
ha detto soreta nel dubbio comunque a
chiaro
ecco sono nati già una volta ho visto
una scena del genere in giappone giuro
su dio eravamo io e mail al parco di non
mi ricordo
ve l'ho raccontata vista già sta cosa
però ve la racconto sempre che fa
stravedere eravamo sto parco ecc
eravamo c'erano delle bancarelle dove
poter mangiare e c'era tanta gente così
erano seduti a mangiare ed era il
periodo in cui era appena uscito poche
mungo a un certo punto che tutti stavamo
già tutti tranquilli o certo punto tutti
si alzano e iniziano a correre come se
avessero visto in me theory non lo so
certo punto si è tutti avevano telefono
in mano abbiamo visto il comune che
correvano telefoni in mano capo che non
va aperto tutti anno abbiamo aperto
pokémon go per capire cosa fosse
successo ed ha sparato un gaydos ma così
uguale c'è la scena più apocalittica
della mia vita incredibile dal punto
invece cineshow che cosa sto vedendo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
vai
guai
il torneo
[Musica]
e ancora io non so cosa ho visto ma
voglio tutto quello che ho appena visto
ma io l'ultima
per la kirin mio dio cosa fossero buone
buonissime buonissimo sta roba
altro che piena non me ne frega niente
di anche da birra la puoi mettere via da
voi citara altro farmaco a latina y
simon werner non era la principale non
ho capito non ho ancora capito adesso ho
capito una patatina scioccarli cardi
ve lo spiego io ragazzi cosa ha detto in
giapponese sono schiavano patatine
antigravitazionali tu le mangi e finisci
su saturno è bellissimo regalo così si
gioca porca vacca se a formaggino una
terra si cita passaggio di referenti ma
non si va beh questo è tutto è una sorta
di spoiler di giorgio in realtà sono
tutti spoiler aveva ragazzi questa
reggia place con marshall molto bello
molto bello anche questa settimana spero
che vi sia piaciuto iscrivetevi al
canale spiaciuta campo adelina per
rimanere aggiornati sui nuovi video che
escono e noi come sempre ci vediamo al
prossimo video della ragazza
[Musica]